KNOW WHO IT COMES DOWN TO.
JOE MANCHIN AND KIRSTEN SINEMA.
BREAKING NEWS ON THE COMMITTEE,
THE
ON JANUARY 6th, THEY'RE PLANNING
TO SUBPOENA JOHN EASTMAN.
HE'S SLAMMINGER McAULIFFE AND
YOUNGKIN.
>> ALSO, LISTEN, IT TALKED TO
YOU A LOT MORE ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE, RIGHT?
THE JANUARY 6th, COMMITTEE, THEY
ARE GETTING THEIR MESSAGE ACROSS
AND THEY'RE NOT PLAYING.
AT LEAST FIVE PEOPLE WHO WORKED
IN THE FORMER ADMINISTRATION ARE
VOLUNTARILY TALKING TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THEY RANGE FROM JUNIOR TO SENIOR
WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS.
THEY'RE NOT WAITING TO BE
SUBPOENAED.
THEY'RE NOT FOLLOWING STEVE
BANNON'S LEAD TO WEED OUT THE
A
DARKEST DAY OF AMERICAN'S
HISTORY.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THE FOUR
STAFFERS ARE.
YOU CAN BET THE FORMER PRESIDENT
IS NOT HAPPY ABOUT THIS
DEVELOPMENT.
SOME OF THEM REPORTEDLY BELIEVE
THAT THEY HAVE INFORMATION WORTH
SHARING AND OTHERS ARE
VOLUNTEERING TO AVOID BEING
SUBPOENAED.
>> A NUMBER OF THEM ARE
HORRIFIED AND SCANDALIZED OF
WHAT TOOK PLACE AND THEY WANT TO
DO THEIR LEGAL DUTY AND COME
FORWARD TO EXPLAIN WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> THE COMMITTEE IS REACHING OUT
TO TWO TOP HOMELAND OFFICIALS
FROM THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
CHAD WOLF AND KEN CUCCINELLI.
THE COMMITTEE IS ASKING THEM TO
VOLUNTARILY WHAT THEY KNOW.
NOW I HAVE SAID IT BEFORE BUT
YOU GOT TO WONDER WHAT HE'S
TRYING TO HIDE.
YOU GOT TO WONDER WHY HE DOES
NOT WANT YOU TO KNOW THE TRUTH.
BUT FAR TOO MANY REPUBLICANS
CAN'T HANDLE THE TRUTH.
THEY ARE TRYING REWRITE THE
HISTORY OF WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6th, MO BROOKS, WHO
TELLS CNN HE HAS NO INVOLVEMENT
OF PLANNING THE ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL.
HE SAYS IF HIS STAFF DID HE
WOULD BE PROUD OF THEM FOR QUOTE
"HELPING TO PUT TOGETHER A RALLY
TO PROTEST VOTER FRAUD AND
ELECTION THEFT."
PROUD?
PROUD OF A RALLY PUSHING THE BIG
LIE OF BOGUS VOTER FRAUD.
REMEMBER WHAT MO BROOKS SAID AT
THAT RALLY?
>> TODAY IS THE DAY AMERICA
PATRIOTS START TAKING DOWN NAMES
AND KICKING ASS.
>> ALL OF THAT IN A "FIRE
PELOSI" HAT.
AT LEAST ONE MEMBER OF THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK TO CONGRESS THAT DAY.
>> I WOULD HOPE THAT MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD BE PROUD TO
COME SPEAK AND TELL HIS SIDE OF
THE STORY AND TO GET IT ON THE
RECORD.
THIS FROM AN ELECTORAL COLLEGE
WHO SAYS AND CLEARLY QUESTIONED
HIS OWN SAFETY BECAUSE HE WORE A
FLAK JACKET AND UNDERNEATH WHEN
HE WENT TO SPOKE AT THE ELLIPSE.
>> AND THEN THERE IS THE QANON
SPACE LASER CONGRESSWOMAN WHO
WOULD YOU BELIEVE WHAT HAPPENED
AT THE CAPITOL WAS NOT THAT BAD
BECAUSE IT WAS HER WORDS, "JUST
A RIOT."
>> JANUARY 6th WAS JUST A RIOT
AT THE CAPITOL.
IF YOU THINK OF WHAT OUR
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE
SAYS, IT SAYS TO OVERTHROW
TYRANTS.
>> I MEAN --
>> JUST A RIOT AT THE UNITED
STATES CAPITOL.
WAS JUST A RIOT.
FIVE PEOPLE DIED.
MORE THAN 100 POLICE OFFICERS
INJURED AND 600 PEOPLE CHARGED
WITH CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR AND SHE'S
TRYING MINIMIZE IT BY CALLING IT
JUST A RIOT AND NOT TO MENTION
THIS GARBAGE ABOUT OVERTURN AND
OVERTHROWING TYRANTS.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN INSURRECTION
TO ME.
THAT'S A MAN CHARGED IN THE
BRUTAL ASSAULT OF OFFICER FANONE
IS GETTING OUT OF JAIL.
A FEDERAL JUDGE RULING TODAY
THAT THOMAS CIBICK DESERVES
HOUSE ARREST AT HIS PARENT'S
HOME.
JUDGE JACKSON APOLOGIZED FOR HIS
ACTION AND HIS ATTEMPT TO
DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM OTHER
CAPITOL RIOTERS FROM JAIL.
THE JUDGE ORDERED HIM NOT TO
WATCH ANY POLITICAL NEWS AND
STAY OFF SOCIAL MEDIA.
THINK OF IT, COME ON.
HE'S AT A TIME OUT.
I AM SENDING YOU TO A ROOM, HAVE
A TIME OUT .
I AM TAKING YOUR PHONE AWAY.
GIVING YOU THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT, I THINK YOU HAVE EARNED.
I BELIEVE YOU DESERVED A CHANCE.
IF YOU VIOLATE MY CONDITION,
THAT WOULD BE AN INDICATION THAT
MY TRUST IS MISPLACED.
IT KIND OF PUTS A WHOLE FACEBOOK
NEWS.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
YOU KNOW -- I WILL TALK A LITTLE
BIT LATER BUT I WILL TALK ABOUT
MICHAEL FANONE.
A FEDERAL JUDGE ORDERING AN
ACCUSED CAPITOL RIOTER TO STAY
OFF SOCIAL MEDIA.
THAT'S JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THE ROLE THAT SOCIAL MEDIA PLAYS
IN TRIGGERING PEOPLE, RIGHT?
MAYBE THERE SHOULD BE SOME
LAWSUITS AGAINST SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES.
SO SHE'S USING THAT IN A LEGAL
JUDGMENT SO TO SPEAK THAN
PERHAPS BABY BAKARI OF SOMETHING
SHE'S SAYING.
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT HOW SOCIAL
MEDIA IS SUCH A BIG PART HOW WE
GOT TO JANUARY 6th IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
IS THAT AN ADMISSION?
IF YOU ARE SAYING STAY OFF
SOCIAL MEDIA.
NOW BACK TO MICHAEL FANONE, I
GOTTEN TO KNOW HIM VERY WELL.
HE'S A FRIEND.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO ENDURE
WHAT HE DID TRYING TO DEFEND THE
UNITED STATES CAPITOL.
OBVIOUSLY HE'S NOT HAPPY ABOUT
THIS.
SOMEONE TRIES TO TAKE YOUR
WEAPON AND YOUR MEANS OF
COMMUNICATIONS.
REALLY - WHAT HE SAYS IS THAT HE
FEELS COMPLETELY ABANDONED BY
THE SYSTEM.
BY THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM AND BY
THE JUDGE, AND BY HIS DEPARTMENT
QUITE FRANKLY, HE FEELS OS
S
OSTRICIZED AND BLACKBALLED AND
DOES NOT UNDERSTAND HOW HE'S
SUPPOSED TO FEEL FOR TELLING THE
TRUTH AND PUTTING HIS LIFE ON
THE LINE, TO SAVE NOT ONLY OUR
DEMOCRACY BUT LIVES.
AND, YOU GET A TIME OUT?
I DID NOT GET A TIME OUT AS A
CHILD.
NOW, PEOPLE GET A TIME OUT.
NOW PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCUSED OF
N
INSURRECTIONS OR TRYING TO
OVERTHROW OUR GOVERNMENT IS
GETTING A TIME-OUT.
THAT'S THE REALITY OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON JANUARY 6th.
THE COMMITTEE HAS TO UNEARTH THE
WHOLE TRUTH IF WE ARE GOING TO
SAVE OUR DEMOCRACY.
ALL OF THIS SHOULD BE LOOKED
INTO.
ALL OF IT.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE SAY OUR COURT
SYSTEM AND THEY SAY CRIMINAL